c'est la semaine du goût qu'on ne change
pas vraiment le sujet la semaine du goût
en france le boussac hier très tôt
vraiment très tôt exemple dans cette
crèche de strasbourg reportage ludovic
fossard sylvain gauthier manon
pâtissière en devenir lauren deux ans et
demi artiste peintre en action et julie
pas tout à fait trois ans mais déjà
caisses trop d'hommes allez on ne
plaisante pas avec la fin surtout quand
on est là pas seulement pour manger mais
aussi pour apprendre et pénétrait ses
mystères de la nature qui donne du goût
aux bonnes choses de la vie
possibilité aux goûts je crois que c'est
aussi sensibilisés au langage qu'est ce
que le personnel il leur parle voilà ce
que c'est sucré salé est ce que ces
acides
donc ça permet aussi d'intégrer tout un
nouveau vocabulaire
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences et une
séance de travail
douze des serres de saveurs 12 monts de
pluie a retrouvé en somme de la
mathématique la gastronomique
habituellement on leur impose finalement
l'alimentation tout cas la crèche on
peut pas se permettre de faire des repas
avec 36 plat pour permettre à chacun de
goûter ce qu'il faut leur impose alors
que là c'était leur permettre de choisir
aussi y goûter de tout et après avez le
choix de s'orienter vers ce qu'il
préférait un voyage à travers le goût
donc qui va durer toute la semaine
chaque jour découverte d'une nouvelle
cuisine histoire d'enrichir la très
jeune expérience culinaire des enfants
mais il faut un peu de temps et quelques
brûlures pour apprendre que quand c'est
bon
c'est parfois trop chaud